i think that's the beauty of what
david's done is it it does
so much more justice than other
iterations to the actual source
materials so much more psychological
and it's not just focusing on like
clashings of swords and things like that
but it's actually about the journey
hello this is dad patel and this is how
i became sick wayne for the green knight
so gawain is the young slightly
headstrong
and spoiled nephew of king arthur and he
finds himself
sitting with the knights of the round
table but he has no real
legacy or real reason to be there so
he's eager to prove himself
you know he's faced with this challenge
to go and face this green knight on this
very futile task
he goes on this journey and is very
quickly stripped of all of his
belongings and he's
kind of sort of goes on a trial by
nature to kind of face this ominous
destiny
i was handed david's script and i was
utterly enthralled they put me in a
spell for you know
weeks after that and i kind of became
obsessed with it the imagery was
ingrained in my brain and i was
constantly pestering my agent so what's
happening without what's happening with
that
i finally got to chat with him and we
really hit it off try to land them
against me indulge me in this game
there's older depictions of gwen like
that are quite chaste and he's very
pure and youthful and there wasn't a law
to this
more scrappy version but there were some
really dislikeable traits which i wasn't
totally against but i was just like you
know
me and david were having conversations
it wasn't like anything was drastically
changed but you know you're on this
journey with this guy for a long time i
mean basically nearly every frame of
this thing so i was like how can we be
with him even when he does really
questionable things and you're quite
frustrated by him in certain
moments and yeah so that was this kind
of
evolving discussion and it's it's david
in his
prowess as a director to really you know
kind of taper and
temper that journey
i feel bad for david because i kind of
was like yeah i can learn how that's
easy you know i'm quite a
physically active guy i found it really
hard they put me on this
really cute very small horse called
sparkles she's he's like one of the
horses on vikings i think one of the
female characters you know writer but i
got on i'm six foot two of my kind of my
my feet were kind of scraping on the
ground so it kind of looked a bit like i
was sitting on a shetland pony or
something
so they upgraded me to something more
robust and it was
this beautiful horse called armani he
he's a real boisterous
uh personality and i i i'm you know i
was kind of like
drowning in all the armor and stuff
anyway in the costumes so to try and
make it look cool was
i don't know i don't think i quite
achieved that but armani i would kind of
i would steal an apple from the lobby of
the hotel every day and go and feed him
in the mornings and
and we we really became tight we became
tight throughout film
it was a really physically kind of
taxing shoot in the sense that i was
in it and there were long shoot days and
short turnovers and it was cold and damp
and in between takes they were running
in and you know throwing a blanket over
the horse because the horse was
freezing as well and it was like it was
a really interesting process but
you know the environment on set was
always so positive
david is such a positive kind beautiful
individual so that kind of trickled
through all the departments in a way
so as as dark or as gloomy or as rainy
as the days got you know he was this
kind of constant source of energy and
light
um but you know we went to extreme
lengths to achieve some of this
imagery you know the whole crew was like
you know select members were
trudging through rivers and it created
these improvised pulley systems to get
the camera
you know equipment up you know to you
know really crazy places so we could get
these beautiful vistas and it really
pays off like every frame really is a
painting in this you know the
compositions are
just insane
christ is born
she's born indeed
alyssia was like a dream to work with
she's so
supremely talented it's kind of
intimidating and she has this kind of
precision
as a performer which someone like myself
who's kind of all limbs can only dream
of but she's an awesome person and she's
juggling these two roles
decided to go a totally different
accents for both of them and
it was it was amazing to work with her
and likewise with joel he kind of
went down the rabbit hole of watching
all of these old
you know british actors oliver reeds and
stuff and he came to set and
was like a totally different person and
he makes her look so effortless and
you've got shawn and also ralph who's
kind of
you know in this massive green knight
you know prosthetic piece costume
but his booming voice just totally you
felt the performance
through it he was amazing when i first
saw him ralph and that makeup i
was he is terrifying up close and the
level of detail that went into just
all of the kind of roots and and veins
on on the prosthetics on his hands
there wasn't an inch of real ralph left
you know his eyes that put these massive
contact lenses in
but he's got this voice you know that
just commands a room and it is like the
voice of destiny and he's such a cool
guy never did he
once every moan or you know
he was a rock star we all
fear but fear can be of give
i am really ambitious and i feel
sometimes you lose sight of
of the joy of doing something because
you're so caught up in something else or
the ambition or
the end goal uh and this story kind of
takes you through the journey
of that yeah there's a beautiful moment
in the film i don't want to give too
much away but you kind of see it
if success was kind of achieved in the
wrong way if it was built on lies and
immoral actions it's a moral lesson in a
way of how that would play out and how
empty that might feel
that really struck me when i read the
script what do you hope to gain
from facing all of this
honor
[Music]
i think that's the beauty of what
david's done is it it does
so much more justice than other
iterations to the actual source
materials so much more psychological
and it's not just focusing on like
clashings of swords and things like that
but it's actually about the journey it
is about this
man's blinding ambition and to to be
someone great
uh the pitfalls of that you know he's so
feeble in a way he starts off so
masculine and boisterous and cocky and
then you kind of
he's put through this trial by nature
and totally has the confidence battered
out of him but
these stories deal with the shivering
code and they they use loftier words but
it's about truth and
integrity and it's you know it's
you know he's trying to be great but can
he maintain being good at the same time
can
he can he achieve should he be striving
for goodness instead of
greatness you know um these are the
questions that this
this story kind of juggles and i think
will always be relevant
that is why knight does what he does
[Music]
are you ready
you